talking about uh the universities you
know we were talking about the program
to teach people
free market and then they had the big
government side we we opened this
uh podcast talking about these kids who
are being indoctrinated they're being
told
they can't succeed because of their race
things like that and
i'm worried that this is going to teach
a generation
not to try they can't be successful and
will make them dependent so
you know when you're telling the story
about how you have this college program
i mean they're going to the grade
schools right now i'm curious what you
think
about you know what our kids are going
through and what do you think is going
to happen with that
i'm worried as we talked about my focus
is those four attributes
you know we talked about and i want it
to be
under 40 because under you know between
15 and
40 this those generations um
you got processed food you got social
media
you got internet you got all this
technology you got all these technical
advices around you got pharmaceuticals
you got super high anxiety he got a
little bit of deterioration of the
family
i'm really worried about that
demographics and
when i hear critical race theory the law
of unintended consequences here
are you know there's going to be
tentacles going every which way
i'm worried that's actually going to
hurt the black community more than it's
going to help them
i agree there's a viral video right now
where this um
there's this black father and it's i
think it's actually one of the best
criticisms of the critic of the critical
race applied principles so
theory would be just uh the academic
literature and the applied principles
would be what they actually tell the
kids and what they implement
and this is a father who says he just
very politely
says hey you know my my kids came home
and they were very scared
and they said that you talked about
slavery and and
jim crow but nothing in between i'd
appreciate it
if you just you know let my kids be kids
and grow up a little bit
because i want them to be the best they
can be but they're being told they can't
so you know and that was basically it
very calm
not this rage filled how dare you is him
just being like look my kids are
freaking out and can we just let them be
kids for a minute
and then i'm like i hear you man yes
kids you what what i don't like about
what's happening these schools and what
worries me is that
you we had this story the other day
fourth graders
being told to go through this critical
race you know applied principles packet
and answer all these questions
and they tell the white kids that you're
oppressors that you're evil
you know that you know you need to
recognize what you've done and your
ancestors
you know the sins of the fathers are
yours and then they tell the children
who are not white that you can't succeed
because
of your race and because of these things
what's going to happen to a kid who's
told they can't succeed they're going to
say
when they fail when they when they
stumble and fall at their knee
they're going to look at the crack in
the ground and say that's the fault of
the white man who made the sidewalk
not me for not paying attention if you
go through life that way
refusing to acknowledge where you have
made a mistake how could you ever
possibly improve
you can't well this whole past thing is
is a problem
um if you take uh two siblings that come
out of an alcoholic family
one grows up and drinks themselves to
death
the other one grows up and is the ceo of
the president
or whatever to fortune and fame and
so you you asked the one that eventually
drank them said well why'd you why'd you
drink somebody he said well
because my parents drink all the time
and then you ask the other sibling that
went to the top
why why didn't you drink and they said
well i didn't drink because my parents
drank and i want to be like my parents
the point of that is the the past
doesn't make the future
the future makes the past this living in
the past
you know i you got to acknowledge it you
got to learn from it
but we can't be worrying about things
that happen you know two three four five
six hundred years ago we need to
identify what's going on right now
and plan for a bright future for all of
us
yeah i think there's a lot of powerful
political interests who recognize
grievances make money media outlets
realize
hey if we can say something that's
shocking and and freak people out
we're going to get paid and then their
special political interests say we will
get votes
whether it's votes or cash there's power
to be had in in fanning the flames of
this stuff
well there's money everywhere that's you
know the medical
system academia i mean it's just a big
money machine the pharmaceuticals we
talked about the billions they give in
lobbyists the food processor
so all of it is gets back to you know
follow the money
for sure but there's at the end of the
day principles
always are more powerful than force and
good
is always supersedes evil we just got to
hang on to it
there are just some bad people who think
i think it's a lack of empathy
in a sense they don't care what happens
to other people perhaps it's a
combination of utilitarianism and
nihilism or callousness or some measure
of each you know
individual idea existing within people
one of my favorite stories i tell people
is this
back when i was uh you know growing up
in chicago there was there were people
who would you know sell pot right
and it was like a really risky thing to
do you know what i mean you might make
money doing it but it's super illegal
and i remember meeting some guy and he
was talking about how people were really
dumb he's like man you got people in
this neighborhood they're so stupid you
know why they sell they sell dope
they're selling pot why would you do
that
and then i was like what do you mean
they're trying to make money it's like
an easy way to make money he's like no
it isn't
he's like you know what i do he's like i
call local venues i ask them
what bands are playing this weekend
friday or saturday i call the band and
say hey i'm going to make shirts for you
to sell to your audience and i'll take
20 percent
and they'd say okay and then you go to a
print shop he'd spend
you know a couple hundred bucks on
shirts sell them all out to this band's
fans make himself a couple grand in a
weekend
totally legally and he was like i make
more money working one day out of the
week
than all of these people selling dope
why are they doing it they're not
thinking
they're being told lies they're being
told it's easy waiting money it's not
true man
there's better ways to make money so i
bring this up because there's a lot of
people
who are grifting who are manipulating
who are trying to make a quick buck
what there's really easy ways to make
legitimate money if you just think and
you work hard
well you know back to this board of
directors i mean you can talk about what
they did
evil this and you know the other and
just how wrong and it's horrific
but it's it's their problem it's not my
problem all i can do every day
is wake up and and put the best version
of jon forward that i can put forward as
long as i'm better
myself and i'm better than the people
around me then hopefully that will
spread
a lot a lot better and a lot more
poignant and a lot more graceful than
people that are doing wrong
i do i believe that so when when uh uh
you're
we had people from your crew show up we
also had a bunch of free
you sent us some pizzas right so we're
downstairs and papa john's pizza shows
up
i was told by uh some of the people who
are working with you that you can they
were like oh send him a picture he will
point out everything that's wrong with
the pizzas
and at first i was like do you mean like
the the since he left they've ruined the
pizzas no no just like
the pizzas aren't perfect right so so
actually one of the first things you do
is you come in you're like let me take a
look
and then you pointed out you know here's
where they made mistakes this should
have done this they should have been
better
i only bring this up because you
mentioned there was a bonus thing that
you had
that you were you are paying out a
decent amount of the profits and bonuses
to your staff that was that that's true
right
well the guest experience can't
uh exceed the um the employees
experience and the employees have a
miserable day of work
they're going to take it out on the
guest so we always put the employees
first
and a big part of that was we made them
feel like owners and we did that through
profit sharing
and if you got the product right and you
got the service right and you had a good
attitude usually the customer was pretty
happy so we we figured out how to
measure that
we put out a great pizza and when they
got it right and they get with good
service and good attitude then we paid
in bonuses in the tens of millions of
dollars
so our employees not only were they
getting promotions and getting raises
they were getting huge
bonuses and so that was what i call a
win-win win-win win
was there a percentage that you
allocated to this well the managers for
st
for example are 20 but it goes right up
from
the manager right up the supervisor
right up even the people in the office
the executives all get paid it's another
thing we did we had the bonus system
aligned from top to bottom
so most corporations the guy not only at
the top gets his
four five six seven million bucks and
the people at the bottom getting taken
advantage of which is
immoral it's unethical um we made it so
that
the guy at the top couldn't get a bonus
unless the folks doing the heavy lifting
at store level got a bonus so the bonus
system had a total alignment total
integrity and that was very that was one
of the most powerful things we did is
bonus from bottom to top it does that
does that system still exist after
you've left
no the first two things they did when i
left was
they took out the measurement system
well if you don't measure it they're not
going to do it
with that measurement measurement met
the quality which you just alluded to
the ten point scale and the quad of the
product
how long it took to get the pizza there
how many times the phone ring did the
driver had had on did the driver smile
that kind of thing
the measurement system the matrix to
measure the quality and what we call
demonstrable value which is basically
the customer experience and the second
thing they took out was
the principles we really are big on
principles
and we think we got to have core values
every company has
core values fedex is going to have
different core values then gm
gm is going to have different core
values than papa john's core values are
nice
and they're uh pretty
you know specific to whatever company
but principles are universal
so mutual respect kindness
thoughtfulness collaborative alliances
win win win
authenticity those are all like gravity
they're just there
and you can fight principles all you
want but principles like gravity sooner
or later are
going to win so we built the company on
principles
and then core values and then
measurement system on quality
and it was very very powerful but that's
the things they took out the first
because those are the hardest things to
do
how did it start well real quick to
follow this point the reason i brought
this up is that bernie sanders
proposed 20 stock sharing with
with the workers so that when profits
come in a quarter of the profits are
divvied up and then sent out to the
workers
it's fascinating to me that you know
i've heard uh quotes from you about
minimum wage being too low
we you're talking now about this bonus
structure and it sounds like a lot of
things the left claims to want
you are actually doing chick-fil-a gives
half the money to their managers half
the profits go to the store manager so
i'm i'm big on ownership and i'm big on
splitting the pie up
um if you give the employees a say
you're making
a hundred thousand bucks a year and you
give employees 30
000 of it um you know believe it or not
within a year or two they're going to
have that number up to 140 or 160. yeah
so you want to make money i know and so
that 70
of a hundred exactly if you had 100 100
within two or three years
the seventy percent of the number is
going to be bigger numbers so yeah it
compounds itself for sure
chick-fil-a they pay their staff really
well also right they do everything well
i mean there's a
they're they're um principle-centered i
don't like to get too much into
religion but they're definitely
spiritual um you know they
they obey universal laws and universal
truths
uh they're very consistent they're
family run so they can do
they can play the long game and um they
take care of their people and
they love uh they love america and they
love humanity they're they're
they were the one company that we always
wanted to be like chick-fil-a yeah
wow thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you